essential adjectives absolutely
necessary extremely important that is
what we're talking about today hi I'm
Nick Jonas and these are my essentials
my first cellphone was a Nokia brick
where you could change out to face the
phone it had the snake game on it no
color screen eventually from there I
upgraded to a sidekick and I held onto
that til I got to the black bear I've
sort of fancied myself a businessman at
the age of 15 and was reluctant to make
the switch to the first generation
iPhone and then I got all the way up to
the 6 and stayed there until just
recently I was gifted this phone the 11
which for some reason has three cameras
four if you include the front and it's
again a life changing experience and
connects me with my family my friends
and my amazing fans all over the world
there have been crucial moments where
not having my cell phone on me was an
obstacle but actually story comes to
mind about my brother and him not having
his phone on him
this was Joe we're big skier some
snowboarder he's too scared and we were
on the mountain and he had a a white
case on his phone he at the top of the
mountain decided to enjoy a little and
as he was on his way down his phone fell
out of his pocket he was trying to take
a picture and he said I'm done I'm too
high to go down this mountain again it's
up to you and I said I will save a day I
will find your white phone I'm it's this
white snowy mountain I then rode down
and like something out of a movie
this guy was stopped and he looked
injured I said hey are you okay and he
looked up he said is this your phone
forty thousand square feet of space on
this white mountain and the one guy I
ran into was the guy holding my
brother's phone I didn't tell him till
nup just now obviously that I had help
but I did save a day and he has me to
thank and just so you know he's not high
anymore my friend introduced me to one
of the finer things in life and no I'm
not talking about excellent tequila
which we'll get to later I'm talking
about low mercury too
now this is delicious it comes in
various flavors tandoori lemon pepper
Cajun lots of great flavors and I fancy
myself a bit of a canned tuna aficionado
if you will I've posted many videos and
tutorials on how to make your own much
like a makeup tutorial although it's
tuna fish instead of makeup I had the
pleasure of being a part of this film
the first iteration of the Jumanji
franchise which were about to release
the second one I was actually watching
the original one with Robin Williams on
a tour bus the day I got the phone call
that I had been cast in the movie so a
little serendipitous and to this day
that is still one of my favorite movies
in the fact that I get to be a part of
this franchise now was really special
one of the things to look out for in
this film is there's one particular
scene where Kevin Hart is crying
unnecessarily in the scene you know he
cries all the time obviously but this
was on camera and it's in the movie
where we were shooting up the mountains
and it was so cold the wind was blowing
in his face and so when it did this
cutaway shot halfway through the film
which you'll see if you go check it out
in theaters he's literally crying and
all of us are crying laughing at him
crying on-screen and I just got the most
joy out of that possible I should text
him now and tell him he's a great crier
[Music]
my job requires me to to work a lot and
travel a lot which means I'm not in my
own bed a lot of time and I was on a
plane once and I looked over at this
very elegant man the most elegant man
I've ever seen in my life
he walked on with a kind of briefcase he
walked on with a duffle bag and he sat
the briefcase down first opened it up
and pulled out an eye mask his own
cashmere blanket and some earplugs he
then put the duffel bag up top proceeded
to tuck himself into bed on this flight
put the eye mask on and look like it had
been done professionally that flight was
over I looked over again and realized it
was none other than Tom Ford the most
elegant person I've ever seen and he
slept in his suit which I also thought
was very impressive
whereas I looked like
you know like a garbage person basically
after that I said I'm gonna find myself
a good sleeping mask the cool part about
this one is that it's actually open here
right so it doesn't pressure your eyes
crucial spoken from a a true eye mask
aficionado I don't know where I came
across this but I never leave my house
without it speaking of Tom Ford I just
recently purchased this portfolio it's
sort of a clutch meets a handbag I guess
but the important thing is that it
elevates everything so I could be
wearing a t-shirt have this with me
suddenly it looks like I actually put in
some work to get out the house the
morning or if I have it with a suit it
fits that as well it doesn't have to be
Tom Ford he's just my inspiration
because he's the most elegant man I've
ever met this was a splurge I made
recently after the tour and seeing the
fans every night and how amazing that
was so I said you know what I need a new
bag I've had the same one for a while
and it treats me pretty well plus it
looks really cool when you do this bag
and then zip it back up so thanks Tom
Ford for all the inspiration for the
portfolio bag for those of you that
don't know that's what it's called
support folio bag tequila a man's best
friend not always the morning after
necessarily but in the moment it is for
sure and with this one it's my best
friend because I co-created this this
brand with John Barbados a very good
friend of mine and collaborator we'd
always had interest in tequila and
wanting to build something together
starting with clothing collaboration and
moving on to the fragrance and then
after all these dinners and things we've
been to together where we talked about
life and family and connectivity and
artistry at the center a lot of those
conversations was tequila we said we're
not we're not professionals we don't
know much about this but we know that we
have an eye for the way we move design
the brand and you know we've drank
enough of it to know what we would want
it to taste like so we went to a Stoli
group and talked with them about
developing his brand they had just
actually purchased a distillery a couple
months earlier so the timing was perfect
and within
you know eighteen months of getting the
juice just right we've got the design
concept for the bottle which this is our
Reposado we've got a silver end in the D
at home for me tequila is is sort of
like champagne in a sense you drink that
with friends at times you're celebrating
when life is good and we wanted to bring
that same energy and idea around tequila
which is that it's life as it should be
it should be with people that you love
and for me my brother's my wife this is
what we drink and whether you're
celebrating or not hopefully you're
around people when you drink this
because it's not good to drink alone but
this is this is good essential to have
in moderation of course this is a
perfect segue here to Bro mask now I
don't like gender stereotypes at all and
I think it's important to recognize that
this is a product that is specifically
catered towards men right bro mask but
this is something men and women can both
use and it is very helpful I don't know
the science necessarily behind it but I
know that I feel a lot better after I
wear this and this started because you
know I was regularly stealing my wife's
products and and she was stealing some
of my products and then someone that I
work with very closely who helps me with
my hair and feeling groomed before I
stepped into things said once you try
this one and this is made by a husband
and wife who have a similar story where
the husband was stealing wife's products
and finally they developed this together
and I just love that sort of was a
parallel to my own life finding a way to
to make men that perhaps do feel
uncomfortable sort of taking extra care
of their skin and other things because
of unfortunate gender stereotypes I
think this is a good starting place for
you or you'll feel a lot better you'll
look your best just good to take care of
yourself that's the reality whether
you're a man or a woman non-binary take
care of yourself feel your best your
body will thank you so bro mask for me
is the way to go and for someone else
might be something else but this is my
essential in addition to taking care of
yourself it's important to smell good I
did a Broadway show a couple years ago
called How to Succeed in Business
Without Really Trying I took over for
Daniel Radcliffe and then Darren Criss
came in for a while now
I had this weird sense of competition
with both those guys who I really love
and admire and have really great
friendships with but the competition was
not so much about the show that we all
played that same role in but more about
our cast mates telling us who smelled
the best so when I teamed up with John
Varvatos I told him the same story said
well why don't we do a fragrance and you
can actually hold the title as best
smelling man in show business and I said
what an idea we launched the blue
fragrance first then a micro Maroons
were red fragrance that came out last
holiday season and this is our newest
one it's sort of electric if you had to
think of a word to describe it it's got
a lot of energy I think it immediately
pops and has an effervescence about it
that makes you kind of want to know more
about not only the fragrance itself but
the person this fragrance to me is all
about challenging yourself I will say
this was inspired by New York the energy
of the city by the artistry and the
creativity within that city both from
again its look and its smell if you
smell it I think you know what I'm
talking about
it'll make you want to get up and do
something and I like making good first
first impressions and this does that but
this isn't essential because I make
money from it marriage and this ring is
that the token of forever
goes back many many many many thousands
of years I believe my Wikipedia page
that pulled up before this is accurate
this one specifically was a gift from my
wife as was hers from me although I've
named all these things as essentials I
try to live without ever really needing
any material item and knowing that if it
was stolen from me or if I ever had to
give it away to somebody or if it was
you know misplaced somehow that I
wouldn't be crushed however this would
be pretty devastating as it sort of
represents the greatest achievement of
my life which is finding someone that I
love care about deeply I wouldn't spend
my life with for those that don't know
that's what a reading wedding ring means
it's the ring that you get on your
wedding day so I'm glad I can help you
understand that hopefully you get one of
these one day - if that's what you want
if not no pressure spike ball it's a
game played by four or more people with
a ball this net and a whole lot of
can-do attitude the idea is simple it's
basically volleyball meets doubles table
tennis and it looks like a sport for
someone that's just done a keg stand
perhaps it's got a sort of a real
fraternity energy to it in the best way
in that it's all about you know sort of
just throwing a ball at a net very
simple concept but my brothers and I
really come to love this while on tour
and it's a good warm-up for us it's not
a highly athletic sport necessarily
although I'm sure there's a lot of
people who disagree with me on the
Internet it will take it very seriously
for us it's more just an enjoyable way
to kill some time and although our
skills are getting better I would say
for the rest of the world probably
watching this at home who aren't in deep
deep you know tournament style spike
both games just get one of these very
easy to get outside of cup of friends
hit the ball around see if you can take
home that the spike ball pride for us
you know it's easy to travel with
although right now trying to show this
as proven to be a little awkward
those are my essentials thank you for
watching
[Music]